hi I'm Larry lunder field agronomist
with Pioneer seeds in Western North
Dakota and today I want to talk to you
about a very important part of your weed
control program and that is
incorporating a pre-emergent herbicide
into that weed control program now
oftentimes we hear I don't like to use a
pre because it might not rain which is
the case it's not the case this year but
some years that is the case but what
adding a pre-emergent does do for you is
it brings additional modes of action for
weed control into your field it helps
you with Troublesome weeds that have
been shown to been resistant to many of
our post-emergent herbicides such as
kosha also what it will do is it will
help you to maintain your post-emergent
herbicides longer as we don't continue
to develop resistance with other weed
species that could become Troublesome
within our fields
now currently we have resistant to
things such as glyphosate
many group two herbicides such as a
sulfonated ureas and many group one
herbicides such as the acc's which are
common commonly used for grass control
and things such as small grain in order
to maintain the chemistries we currently
have on the market we will need to be
very judicious in our management of
these herbicides so incorporating a pre
into those
systems will be critical in order to do
that long term
we are demonstrating
many of these pre-technologies and what
they can do in our enlist executive
plots across North Dakota and
Northwestern Minnesota this year and we
invite you out to visit those on our
tour dates in July
and I will leave you with one more
thought and that is
cleaner Fields will give you bigger
yields
that concludes this Pioneer Agronomy
video podcast visit our page on
pioneer.com and follow us on Twitter and
Facebook for more Agronomy insights
[Music]